you are just looking like a million
bucks you look amazing I made the dress
myself yeah right is that why a few of
the beads have come off I made that part
I'm afraid I'm leaving a trail behind me
so it's okay and what a trail it is I
gotta say this guy right here you seem
to be smiling a little bigger Tonight
George I wonder why is that I'm thinking
I'm thinking because Brad Pitt finally
admitted to the world yes it's fine it's
time it's time he finally admitted that
that I'm the guy I agree it's the guy
you are the guy I'm also thinking maybe
you're beaming a little bit tonight
because you just celebrated your eighth
wedding anniversary
pretty amazing yeah eight so special for
the two of you well it's better than not
right since we've been married for eight
years it's really important we're just
we just feel really lucky we're having a
really wonderful time now we got two
five-year-old kids running around too
and speaking all sorts of languages that
we don't speak it's an issue
you celebrate your eighth
year so what did you how did you
celebrate for your beautiful bride now
you think I'm gonna you think I'm going
to tell you we went to one of our
favorite new restaurants yes and we had
a lovely dinner quiet dinner we got a we
had a big event
for this really do you take twins on
your anniversary no you do not George no
you really yeah they would have been
conspiring against you in Italian and
all sorts of other languages but tonight
is all about the army awards so tell us
about the awards what do they represent
and what what do we need to know about
these honorees
well all of them they're sort of Justice
Warriors we like to call them they're
all people who are at risk they're doing
really amazing things where we raised as
a journalist in the Philippines who's
doing everything she can to try to talk
about corruption and she's facing 85
years in prison and so and we have a lot
of all of our awardees are at risk and
our our job is to try and I think I
can't think of a better reason to have
an award show than to try to draw
attention to somebody and make it maybe
a little harder to throw them in jail
I'm all you and George take time from
your busy careers from your families why
is this something that you're just so
passionate about and what do you hope
people at home will take from this red
carpet experience tonight in this award
ceremony well for me it's an extension
really of what I can do as a lawyer
individually but here we can do it at
scale so it's the same people I could
take on as clients victims of genocide
of Human Rights abuses journalists who
are locked up but I can only represent a
certain number as an individual lawyer
through the foundation we're now in more
than 40 countries and it's just been a
amazing to see the response that we've
gotten for tonight and in terms of all
of our allies so I think the message is
there's so much that people can do
tonight we have businesses represented
we have ngos we have law firms and just
people who want to play that part and
and it really it works yeah it really is
incredible what the two of you have
created you have quite the catch I've
done quite well thanks
I didn't know that yeah I know you have
my approval for whatever you needed it
thanks for coming now thank you
[Music]